how's the gum resumes today we're gonna
play swing copters it was made by the
same guy who made flappy birds
I guess he's back I guess he's like you
know what you guys want pain
I'll give you pain but I gotta check it
out no way it can be harder than flappy
bird what the [ __ ] is this
come on tap tap tap
what why does my eyes look like a boob
come on this is a joke it's this some
curl joke don't I know I can't get one
at least give me one don't don't
it's it looks easy but he's out of
control man tap oh oh you back now huh
yeah that's cool man that's cool look
look how I'm tapping oh I don't have to
tap ah
sorry I wasn't trying to hit on you come
on chief I just want one point so I can
show off to my mom come on what Oh God
you ruined my I scored no flying I
didn't have a high score there's a low
score in this game yes
gosh - I'm the best player in the world
I never been this happy to get a to
score wasn't flappy bird enough you've
really had to come back to do with this
to a time oh thanks
I'm playing airplane mode so you don't
get any [ __ ] money from the ad I'm
sorry
[ __ ] flappy [ __ ] I know it's you in
there I see I know a flat paper itch
when I see one all right dad tap that ah
ah
that might sound weird out of context
that also might seem weird out of
context my iPad is a combination of spit
and blood right now
Oh ZOTAC works oh I get it it changes
direction every time I tap oh my god I'm
the dumbest [ __ ] laughs it'll
make sense
but I still suck why do I still suck Oh
tap that I'd tap that is tap tap tap tap
[ __ ] I'm gonna be too if it's the last
thing I'll ever do there right yeah you
think you know someone but then they
just tap your ass man this game is
probably the most life inspiring piece
of [ __ ] play flappy bird they said it
will be fun they said I'm not gonna make
any more games they said swing copter up
your ass they said darling envelope Oh
Mina Bangkok or give me three where is
he going anyway what is your motivation
he doesn't even care well at least you
don't have Botox like flappy bird
I just realized I make a great [ __ ]
fountain yes
yes [ __ ] yes the best player in the
world I need to install like a
windscreen for my for my iPad because
their spit going in all places here [ __ ]
you
I'm sorry I'll stop swearing it's not
funny and it's inappropriate think of
all the children think of all the people
who get offended shoot [ __ ] you
think you're a flappy hoe and then you
just realize you have a flappy [ __ ]
hole oh my god I think I'm starting to
get the gist of this do you like
diamonds in your [ __ ] oh my god me
too
Becky we should really date and hate and
state [ __ ] I don't even know what I just
said all right I'm sorry it took me a
long time but now I finally realize how
to [ __ ] play this [ __ ] [ __ ] yes
you want to [ __ ] me [ __ ] you
no [ __ ] anyone [ __ ] what should we call
him come on potato salad
come on potato salad potato salad potato
salad the guy who made this game really
just wants to see the world burn huh
really no that's fine I appreciate that
I appreciate when you try to skate off
my potato salad yeah eight all right
that's great
haha I don't want to play more I'm sorry
I'm really sorry I don't know what's
gonna happen if I don't touch it
but if you want you can download the
game it's free see if you can beat my
high score if you do then catch for you
get freaky you know I get for you get
for you get for you but anyway thank you
for watching this video and thank you
for leaving like I really appreciate it
and as always thanks for hanging out
with me today
it's the brokest State